oh gee kid is your mother speaking hello
my name is adam smith from
nobelprize.org the official website of
the nobel prize in stockholm oh thank
you for going first of all of course
congratulations on the award of the
Nobel Prize thank you so it must have
been the most extraordinary week you've
been having yes I was so surprised so
yeah he quite extraordinary for me have
you managed to find even a moment to
yourself or have you been in the public
eye the whole time uh yeah my university
stuff Oh manage my schedule so I cannot
manage by myself and you were in France
when you heard the news were you were
you traveling when the news broke or did
you get a call or what happened yeah I
saw in the PC my busy during the transit
at Frankfurt Airport and I found many
many email under I I still did not
understand what happened and when i
arrived at Liam airport then I found
that I received as one of the earth says
the the winner so I was so surprised it
must have been a very confusing flight
from Frankfurt while you wondered what
was going on yeah it's one of the most
amazing travel for me and now that the
news has had a few days to sink in how
do you feel about it yeah more than
herpes but now I'm wondering how to act
yeah because the many people are
watching me so I should ask other babe
very for the first shooting impossible
results yes suddenly you have to be very
grown-up
yeah yeah sure the invention that the
prize has been awarded for is everywhere
everywhere you look you see the blue LED
I mean how does that make you feel to
have been part of something that is now
everywhere oh yeah so for me it's my
great honor that many people use blue
LEDs or LED lighting now so we can
contribute to the energy savings for the
humans so I'm very very happy to
contribute to the energy seven issues
and it must be a great joy to be awarded
together with your supervisor he sorry I
sake yeah what did he teach you oh he
did me and that the nitrate granham
nitride was very very hour is very
promising material for the blue LED so I
could concentrate on the game night
right and not other materials like zinc
selenide was silicon carbide it's now
the evening coming up in Japan what do
you have scheduled for the evening do
you have a free evening for once oh yeah
I'm free that's nice so when did you
come back to Japan October tennis the
day Friday morning oh there must have
been an amazing welcome oh yes yes there
are many many interviewers rd able so i
was subtracted my mother ID a people's
or gather and say say congratulation but
anyway i'm very happy to add my voice to
those congratulations so once again
thank you very much for speaking to us
now thank you so much thank you very
much indeed bye bye bye right